foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear my little movie review Series so I
remember back in 2006 uh when this
zombie comedy movie called Fido first
came out and at the time I was like
really really interested to see it I
mean it looked like a hilarious concept
um it had the delightful Scottish
comedian Billy Connolly um as you know
as the zombie and I was still kind of
feeling a lot of I guess like residual
Goodwill toward the zombie comedy genre
uh because you know Shaun of the Dead
had come out only a couple of years
before and of course that was a classic
but then like for whatever reason
um I never I just never got around to
seeing Fido and sadly it really seems to
have become one of those kind of largely
forgotten movies that people don't
really talk about all that much anymore
so when I was scrolling through 2B the
other day and I saw that it was free to
watch I thought that I would finally be
like oh I've been wanting to see that
for like a really long time and I'd kind
of forgotten about it so it's like why
don't I just Rectify that embarrassing
oversight like right now and I'll give
it a look and I'll review it for the
show and now I have to admit I'm kind of
kicking myself for waiting 16 God damn
years to watch this movie because it's a
great movie I mean it's really really
good uh it's very funny it's very
heartfelt um has some gore in it as well
and it has like a really good like very
dry like black humor also has some very
very sharp social satire that's
presented like in such a Charming way
that it never really feels like forced
or shoehorned in or anything like that
now I've seen it pitched in more than
one review as essentially what if George
Romero had directed Pleasantville like
the movie from 1998 and I will say
that's a fairly accurate summation that
gives you like a ballpark of what the
movie is like but I kind of feel like it
has I don't know like a lot more Scrappy
lovable boldness to it then maybe that
brief very glib description would
suggest so Fido is a Canadian movie and
it was directed by a guy named Andrew
Curry now in it here's kind of like the
the thing for it it posits a sort of
alternate idealized 1950s where the
planet Earth traveled through some sort
of space radiation like at some point
prior to the 1950s which was actually I
guess kind of like a nod to Ned living
dead because that was also space
radiation or that's what they thought
the cause of the zombie outbreak was
so this radiation like reanimated all
the corpses and transformed them into
flesh eating zombies obviously now in
the universe of this movie you don't
have to get bit by a zombie to become
one like everybody will become a zombie
after they die which like I said later
on like The Walking Dead did that as
well
now at some point in the past like prior
to the events of the film there was
apparently a series of zombie wars in
which you're led to assume like lots and
lots of people as well as lots and lots
of zombies were wiped out
now in the wake of all these wars though
uh there was a large corporation called
zomcon which essentially like emerged
Victorious right like they figured out a
way to fit the remaining zombies with
special collars that would Tamp down
their people-eating urges and allow them
to be used for like manual labor or just
like you know jobs that didn't take a
lot of you know what I mean like but you
know just like being servants or picking
up garbage or whatever the hell you know
what I mean just like kind of manual
labor type jobs
uh now as it is stands like when the
movie starts 90 of the population uh you
know essentially like the 90 that are
poor
are just allowed to zombify after death
and are then like turned into servants
by zomcon
um you know and they sell them to people
like as servants while the top ten
percent obviously the elite the rich
people get fancy funerals uh complete
with separate head coffins to ensure
that they don't reanimate because like I
said you have to cut that off now
although this isn't I mean this isn't
explicitly stated in the movie but I
felt like the insinuation was that
zomcon uh essentially runs the
government you know what I mean or like
is the government in some fashion
there's not really I mean this is pretty
contained to one town like the story is
so it's like you don't really get much
of a sense of like the wider world but
that was like the implication that I got
like they have these trucks that kind of
like Patrol these very pleasant
tree-lined Suburban streets or whatever
and they vary discreetly like round up
any zombies that are Troublesome and
they take them back to the factory for
like tune-ups periodically and stuff
like that if if their collar isn't
working right uh they also produce these
hysterical like educational short films
one of which actually like opens the
movie and sort of like explains the
premise like to the audience
um and these short films are like
essentially like about the zombie Menace
like they're made for school kids and
one of the funniest things in it is that
one of the things is that uh they have
to remind everybody that elderly people
are never to be trusted because they
could drop dead at any moment and like
become one of the undead they could
zombify so you can't like trust them at
any time and uh another thing too that
they're kind of pushing hard is that all
citizens like even children should
always be like armed at all times and
like ever Vigilant in case like some
zombie [ __ ] goes down
so like in the thing like there there's
like a uh you know like a scene in the
school like where they teach them they
you know the kids like learn everything
by like rote memorization and they even
have like a little rhyme that's like
taught to the school children in the
brain and not the chest headshots are
the very best that they have about the
yard like practicing like uh with their
rifles and stuff like that on like
little zombie targets and [ __ ] like that
like that's their class that they call
it like outdoor activities or something
like that so the funniest thing about
all this is that it's all like couched
in this idyllic atmosphere of a very
wholesome like 1950s sitcom like Lassie
or Leave it to Beaver not like in a real
self-aware kind of way you know what I
mean like because you know how there's
that kind of different difference where
it's like something could just either be
genuinely like that or it's like that
and it's like aware that it's like that
so it's kind of like winking at the
audience this one is not really winking
at the audience which I think makes it
funnier
so I mean none of the characters in the
movie like think any of this stuff
that's going on is particularly weird or
Sinister like why would they um that's
just like the way that they grew up this
is the world that they know it's just
the way that things are and this is the
way that things have to be like in order
to maintain their kind of like cushy
lifestyles in Suburbia right so nobody
um really even seems all that bothered
by the fact that anybody that causes any
kind of dissension is apparently sent to
what they call the wild Zone which is
like outside of the safety of the town
where all the zombies like are allowed
to kind of roam around uncontained and
you sort of have to like fend for
yourself you don't have zomcon out there
to like protect you so the action in the
movie takes place in this town called
Willard and we're following the Robinson
family so the mom is named Helen and
she's played by Carrie Anne Moss who is
great in this uh dad is called Bill and
he's played by Dylan Baker who is also
great and their son Timmy who's probably
like 11 11 12 years old something like
that who's played by cassan Ray now
initially the Robinsons are kind of
portrayed as this very stereotypical
like 50s family ideal mom is like this
dutiful housewife who always looks
perfect like with the pearls and the
high heels never has a hair out of place
all that kind of stuff and dad is kind
of like sort of goofy distant uninvolved
like he just wants to while away his
weekends playing golf with the boys he
doesn't really want to spend time
hanging out with his wife or his kids or
anything like that so there's also kind
of like this unspoken I guess like
undercurrent of sort of consumerism and
like keeping up with the Joneses and
stuff like that very much like something
from the 50s would have been uh
appearances are Paramount like it's the
most important thing so when the new
head of security at zomcon who is a guy
named Jonathan bottoms and he uh moves
in or he's played by um Henry zerny I
guess is how you pronounce that guy's
last name uh he moves in with his family
like across the street from the the
Robinsons and at that point like Helen
starts to agitate for their family like
getting a zombie Serpent of their very
own because she's really really
embarrassed to be in the only family in
town that doesn't have at least one
zombie because she's like saying to her
husband she's like you know they you
know the new head of security had just
moved in across the street they have six
zombies and we don't even have one and
like people are talking you know what I
mean so it was that kind of stuff now
the reason that they don't have a zombie
is because of Bill now although bill
will never admit this out loud bill is
actually kind of like terrified of
zombies ever since he was forced to kill
his dad when he was a child like after
his dad zombified in front of him and
like tried to eat him so he kind of has
a lot of like residual trauma about that
but Helen of course like I said she's
very um status conscious so she kind of
goes behind his back and buys a zombie
for them anyway and although like Bill
is pretty pissed off about it but he
kind of like grudgingly goes along for
the sake of sort of like I guess
conforming to the community standards he
just wants to look like and seem like
everybody else on the street he doesn't
want to stand out so their son Timmy
meanwhile is having his own problems uh
he's constantly being bullied in school
uh particularly by these two boys who
were kind of like oh Kazam Khan also has
like a thing like a boy scouts type of
thing where they're kind of like you
know like they're a little recruit so
like little zomcon Scouts and they have
little uniforms and everything so two of
those little boys like beat up on Timmy
all the time one day though like while
the boat the bullies are picking on him
the zombie like intervenes and frightens
the [ __ ] kids away and after this
like Timmy kind of begins to befriend
this you know just groaning zombie and
so he names him Fido and starts teaching
him to like Fetch and play catch and
things like that
um and this whole kind of whole
situation is like it's funny but it's
also like kind of bittersweet because
Timmy is clearly in need of a father
figure that bill is you know either
unable or unwilling to provide to him so
the boy is basically like using the
zombie as like a surrogate dad and as
the movie goes on too it starts to
become like equally obvious that Helen
the wife is also starting to recognize
the zombies like humanity and also kind
of has a thing where she realizes that
Fido can maybe like give her the
attention that her husband won't it
doesn't get like too like gross or like
necrophilia or anything like that at but
you know it does kind of like uh suggest
that a little bit so not too long into
this whole uh situation the whole story
or whatever
it so happens that Fido's collar
malfunctions not necessarily
malfunctions it happens in a particular
way but I'm not going to spoil it and he
ends up like partially eating a horrible
neighbor lady which actually ends up
causing a minor zombie outbreak in
Willard because you know once he kind of
partially eats her obviously she wakes
up and she's a zombie and then you know
what I mean and she's like laying in the
park nobody knows she's dead for a while
a while so a couple other zombies are
like running around and eventually
there's like an investigation that sort
of like leads back to Fido and so leads
back to the Robinson family so it's
starting to like threaten this little
family that Timmy is starting to
establish like the friendship that he's
starting to establish with the zombie
and like uh the relationship that his
mom is starting like the friendship that
his mom is starting to have with the
zombie as well like I said is they're
kind of like recognizing that the zombie
is a person like kind of becoming
curious about the person he used to be
like before he died and stuff like that
so I mean one of the great things about
this movie like among the many things
is just the subtlety of it and it's just
like the humor is just very affable it
just has like this really friendly like
gentle kind of humor like this
over-the-top premise totally works
because everything is presented like
very matter-of-factly like very
pragmatically like even when for example
like Helen like toward the end has to
kind of like step up like take out some
zombie kids and you basically like burn
down the evidence like you keep from
getting caught
um she's basically she's not hysterical
she's not hand ringing nothing like that
she just kind of like does what she
needs to do like to protect her family
which and she's just like completely
unflappable uh you know and Resolute
like the whole time because that's just
everybody in this world has grown up
around zombies so they're all kind of
like prepared like if something goes
wrong they're very like calm about it oh
well headshot bang you know what I mean
so they're not like they don't get like
upset about us and I think they I think
they did a good job of like portraying
that where it's not really that big a
deal you know what I mean like I'm
you're led to believe that like the
zombies don't bust out like that often
but everybody has had it drilled into
them from childhood that it could happen
and it's like everybody has to be
prepared like in case it does happen so
everyone is just kind of like ready for
ready for like any kind of like
anomalies when they occur um and I have
to say I mentioned this earlier but
Carrie Anne Moss uh she kills it in this
movie uh she kind of like finds this
perfect balance between like I said just
kind of like this perfect status
conscious 50s housewife like your
stereotypical type of June Cleaver type
of woman and this very obviously like
very strong very almost kind of like
very desperate woman who's you know
yearning to break free from her very
humdrum life it's like she wants romance
she wants excitement she wants things
she realizes that her husband isn't
really gonna give that to her this
environment isn't really going to give
that to her and you can kind of like see
that reflected even though like I said
said it's very very subtle and really I
mean all of the characters in this are
way more nuanced and a lot more like
finely drawn than you would expect or
even that you would like have to be like
considering that you know this is a
zombie comedy movie like you wouldn't
expect there to be like these kind of
richly drawn characters but they
actually are and all of them have their
own like really good like character Arc
and I think this really plays well with
the whole theme of the movie which is
kind of you know again like gently
skewering this enforced Conformity and
you know the subservience to the
appearance of perfection that sort of
like categorized that era like the 1950s
era I mean for example this is a really
good example of that of what I'm talking
about like
um the Robinson's neighbor whose name is
Mr Theophilus and he's played by Tim
Blake Nelson he's kind of introduced as
though he's going to be like some kind
of weirdo or like pervert or something
like that because he dresses like you
know Hugh Hefner by way of Hunter S
Thompson and he has a young zombie woman
in his house who's named Tammy and is
obviously his girlfriend you know what I
mean even though like nobody says that
out loud but everyone's like like we
know that she's not just like doing made
work in there so it's that kind of thing
so you can see that they're kind of like
setting him up like that but he ends up
being essentially like one of the heroes
of the movie so I like that they kind of
like it subverted those expectations I
mean it's just kind of like these
delicate shades of depth that are
revealed about each character like as
the story plays out I mean even the very
aloof and dorky and almost like
comically detached bill is you know
again shown to have his own issues that
are kind of like informing his behavior
and he also kind of like gets a little
bit of a Redemption Arc like toward the
end I also have to give a particular
shout out to the awesome Billy Connolly
here who plays Fido the zombie he has
zero lines of dialogue in the entire
movie and yet uh still manages to convey
like a very very large array of emotions
using nothing but there's just kind of
like rotting face that he has and is
very stilted like body movements uh I
think one of the particular highlight is
these these really creepy these like
toothy kind of smiles that he does I
can't do it but it's just like it's just
uh they're like hysterically funny and
also like really really unsettling at
the same time like he generally like
looks like a Walking Corpse but he's
also like really really sympathetic and
he's really funny without being like
really overt uh the cinematography in
this is also beautiful
um it actually looks way more expensive
than the movie's very modest budget uh
would indicate uh everything is very
very colorful and almost slightly hyper
real not maybe not quite as stylized as
like you know Edward Scissorhands or
something like that but more along the
lines of um if you guys remember that
movie Far From Heaven like from 2004 or
something like that or more recently
like maybe the Mad Men TV series like
that kind of it has that kind of Sheen
to it which I think is like really um it
really ties in well like with the story
so even though this movie isn't quite as
zany I guess as Shaun of the Dead
although Shauna doesn't all that zany
either but
um it's so it's not quite as zany as
that but I thought Fido was every bit as
funny as Shaun of the Dead even though a
lot of the gags are kind of maybe
slightly like slightly low-key like for
example like you know Life Magazine like
some of people are reading that except
now it's called death but it has like
the same logo and everything like that
uh and this is like never pointed out
overtly it's just kind of like a
background type of thing and a lot of
the humor is kind of like that where
nothing is like pointed to it's just
like in the background you have to
notice it and I think a lot of the humor
too comes from the really practical very
like nonchalant reactions that the
characters have to the situations that
they find themselves in I mean the whole
movie too like works pretty brilliantly
as a satire not only of kind of like the
McCarthy era and the Red Scare and all
that kind of stuff but also of the
particular political climate at the time
that it was made particularly [ __ ] like
the Patriot Act and stuff like that and
really of kind of any overarching system
of corporatism and Conformity that you
know maybe marginalizes those who are
different or anything like that so it's
satirizing a lot of that even though
it's specifically satirizing the 50s
like the Conformity of the 50s I mean
that all sounds really deep I guess but
Fido it's not a polemic it's not like in
your face about it it's really it's just
like a fun very humorous film like with
a lot of heart to it and the underlying
themes are there if you want to unpack
them or if you want to like notice them
or if not it's just like a fun funny
movie just on its own so I'm actually
really happy that I finally got around
to seeing this movie after all this time
uh as it really was delightful it was it
was a treat seriously um I I just
laughed my ass off so many times but I
mean I just hope that one day it is able
to kind of like Garner the massive cult
following that it originally deserves
because like I said I really feel like
not a lot of people talk about it
anymore and that's kind of a shame
because I think this is every bit every
bit as good as Sean of the Dead
um so if you haven't seen it then I
would advise like checking it out let me
tell you know tell me what you thought
about it like I said it's on 2B for free
at least as of this recording or if
you've seen it like let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
I'll see you guys again on the next one
bye